- This video was made
possible by Tab for a Cause.
Raise money for charity
just by opening new tabs
which you were going to do anyway.
The coronavirus is wrecking
havoc on the world.
Gone is the basketball
season, the summer Olympics,
and, unfortunately, baseball.
But at least the Nationals
will remain World Series
champions for another year.
So many things are getting canceled
that people are wondering
what else could possibly be canceled
before this thing is over.
Particularly, people are worried
about the upcoming Presidential election.
Once considered completely unthinkable,
people are now legitimately
asking this question,
especially since this has already impacted
the political process.
Already several democratic
primaries have been postponed,
even within hours of their
scheduled primary date.
For example, Ohio Governor Mike DeWine
actually asked the State Supreme Court
to postpone their primary election.
When the Ohio Supreme
Court denied his request
he simply ordered the polls closed,
effectively circumventing
the court's decision.
- This is not about politics.
This is about protecting
Ohio's citizen's lives.
- So if it's possible to
postpone a primary election,
can the general election
be postponed as well?
It's natural to wonder if President Trump
already has a legally
plausible plan up his sleeve
to just cancel the election entirely
and start a 2nd term in office unelected.
So can the president
actually cancel the general
election this November?
The answer will surprise you.
(orchestral music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because our democracy is at
stake, or is it? (eagle caws)
There's certainly a lot of uncertainty
about the November election
and that was even before
the current pandemic.
Will we be standing in line
to vote with masks and gloves
or will we be able to mail in our vote
or will President Trump just take over
and become the dear leader for life
as all true Americans want him to?
Well, today we're going
to discuss whether or not
the president can actually
cancel the general election
and all of the wacky legal
implications that this has.
Full disclosure, some of
the issues in the analysis
in this episode come from the
podcast Opening Arguments.
Opening Arguments is a great podcast
run by Attorney Andrew
Torrez and Thomas Smith.
Andrew took a deep dive into this subject
in response to a thought experiment
by Vox journalist Ian Millhiser.
I'll drop a link to the
Opening Arguments podcast
in the doobly-doo.
Definitely check it
out, it's really great.
So the question is can Trump
cancel the general election?
Now look, I'm not going to bury the lead
and make you sweat
through this entire video
to get to the answer.
The bottom line is
the president cannot
legally cancel the election.
It probably won't happen.
Now, could he try?
Well sure, anyone can try anything
just like anyone can sue
another person over anything
but it doesn't mean that
they're going to be successful.
But no matter what way you slice it,
even with President
Trump's ever expansive view
of his Article II presidential powers.
- Then I have an Article II
where I have the right to do
whatever I want as president
but I don't even talk about that.
- Even he can't take steps
that would effectively
morph his presidency
into a dictatorship.
That's because the Constitution itself
places specific parameters
on presidential terms,
including the length of a president's term
as well as the specific date and time
as to when that term ends.
But that's just the beginning
of the insanity that would happen
if the election were in fact canceled,
and in this context I'm
using the word canceled
to mean the president actually puts troops
and prevents people from
actually going to the polls
because he can't legally
cancel the election,
so we're talking about some
really drastic moves here.
Now, that being said
the Constitution states,
"The President shall hold his office
"during the term of four years."
And even more specifically it
states in the 20th Amendment
that his term,
"shall end at noon on
the 20th day of January."
Very specific, not much wiggle room.
Furthermore, the President is elected
by each of the state's
electors under Article II
of the Constitution
and Congress determines
the time of choosing of the electors
and the day on which they
shall give their votes.
Remember, the President it
elected not by popular vote
but by the electoral college
and you'll see later in this video
even if President Trump opts out
to become a squatter in the White House,
legally the presidency
would pass to somebody else,
effective on the 29th of January, 2021.
Now, I could already hear
you saying in the comments,
great, thanks for the quick
constitutional law lesson
but regardless of what
the Constitution says,
could the President
still find some shady way
to use the coronavirus to his advantage
to postpone or possibly
cancel the November election.
For instance, can the
president declare martial law
due to the pandemic and legally
circumvent the Constitution?
Well, the answer to this and
any other similar question
is mostly no.
More specifically, when it
comes to the Constitution
there's no known circumstance
that can suspend the
enforcement of the Constitution,
not a pandemic, not a
natural disaster, not a war,
and not even a war fought between citizens
of the same country,
specifically the Civil War,
and believe me, it was tried.
And that was the case in the
famous constitutional law case
of Ex parte Milligan
which is the seminal case
for simply saying that the
Constitution is the Constitution
and no matter the circumstances,
the Constitution applies.
Ex parte Milligan was
born out of the events
surrounding the Civil War.
Like a pandemic, a civil war
is an unprecedented event
and President Lincoln suspended
the writ of habeas corpus,
which was an unconstitutional event.
So the first question is in this context,
what is a writ of habeas corpus?
A writ of habeas corpus, as
you've probably seen in movies,
is a federal tool uses to bring
a prisoner before the court
to determine if their imprisonment
or detention is lawful.
The drafters of the Constitution
actually considered a
writ of habeas corpus
to be so important
that they included the concept
of petitioning the court
for a release of a prisoner
who's unlawfully detained
in the first Article of
the actual US Constitution,
not in the Bill of Rights,
not in the Amendments,
but in the actual Constitution itself.
Now, Article I states that,
"The privileges of the
writ of habeas corpus
"shall not be suspended unless
"when in cases of rebellion or invasion
"the public safety may require it."
President Lincoln suspended
the writ of habeas corpus
at the same time that
he declared martial law.
Martial law is basically the law
administered by military forces
that is invoked by a
government in an emergency
when the civilian law enforcement agencies
are unable to maintain
public order and safety.
And by the way, it's martial
law spelled M-A-R-T-I-A-L
not Marshall spelled M-A-R-S-H-A-L-L.
This is not some guy named
Marshall, it's martial as in war,
war-like law, it's just
a pet peeve of mine
that I see people misspelling
all the time on social media.
Anyway, notwithstanding, the
facts of ex parte Milligan
involved a racist lawyer by
the name of Lambdin P. Milligan
who was charged with conspiracy
against the United States.
aiding and abetting the confederacy,
and inciting insurrections.
Now, when Lincoln suspended
the writ of habeas corpus
and declared martial law,
the government tried to
circumvent the courts
and said that Milligan
could be legally tried
in a military tribunal
instead of through the
civilian court system
where he was quickly convicted
and sentenced to hang.
But, before Milligan could be hanged
he sued to stay the execution
and the Supreme Court agreed with him
saying that you can't
suspend habeas corpus.
The Supreme Court held that
it was unconstitutional
to try civilians by military tribunal
unless there were no
civilian courts available,
which wasn't the case.
In support of the Supreme Court's holding,
the court noted, and
here's the important part,
that citizens have certain
rights by the Constitution
such as the trial by jury
and that this constitutional
guaranty was quote,
"intended for a state of war
as well as a state of peace
"and is equally binding
upon rulers and people
"at all times and under
all circumstances."
Bottom line, if Lincoln couldn't
get around the Constitution
while Americans were literally
at war with each other,
then President Trump
doesn't stand a chance
of being able to step outside the confines
of the Constitution due to
the coronavirus pandemic.
But, could President
Trump try to reschedule
or postpone indefinitely the election?
Well, as President Trump
is finding out the hard way
regarding emergency powers,
a lot of election power
resides with the states.
Article I states that, "The
times, places, and manner
"of holding elections for
senators and representatives
"shall be prescribed in each state
"by the legislature thereof,
but the Congress may
"at any time by law make
or alter such regulations
"except as to the places
of choosing of senators."
So election law is really up to the states
with a little bit of oversight
from Congress and the Constitution.
Federal laws have long been on the books
that dictate when the
President, Vice President,
and members of Congress are elected.
You can look to three US C
one, which states that quote,
"The electors of the
president and vice president
"shall be appointed in each state,
"on the Tuesday after the
first Monday in November,
"in every fourth year
succeeding every election
"of a President and Vice President."
Similar laws set the date
senators and congresspeople
start their term, the
third day of January.
These laws are incredibly specific
and nothing in them provides any exception
for the President to
move these dates around.
And since we have federal
statutes in place,
people should have solace
that the President cannot
simply reschedule the election.
As democratic presidential
candidate Joe Biden put,
"We voted in the middle of the Civil War,
"we voted in the middle of
World War I and II," and so
"The idea of postponing the
electoral process," it just,
"seems to me out of the question."
- This is about making sure
that we're able to conduct our democracy
while we're dealing with a pandemic.
- So, now we've established
the Constitution
and federal statutes are specific
about when the elections take place
and when the president's term ends.
Both the Constitution and federal statutes
can only be changed by a
subsequent act of Congress
to amend them, and the president
can't take any unilateral action
to supersede them independently.
But President Trump has
repeatedly stated his belief
that Article II gives him absolute power.
- It's a thing called Article II.
Nobody ever mentions Article II.
It gives me all of these rights
at a level that nobody
has ever seen before.
We don't even talk about Article II.
- So what if in the coming
months President Trump thinks
that he might lose the general election?
What could President Trump do?
Well, there are basically two
things that President Trump
could attempt to do to remain in office.
He could try to convince the states
to take away their citizen's
right to vote for president
or he could try to use the military
to physically prevent people from voting.
The first scenario is much more plausible;
though, still very, very unlikely.
Because the 50 states
hold considerable power
in determining the rules for elections,
including federal elections,
then that happens to take
place within their borders.
The states can control
the method of voting
that will be used,
whether or not a felon can
vote for example, and what,
if any, identification voters
much show at the polls.
Though, of course there are
some constitutional limitations
to those kind of restrictions,
namely from the 15th Amendment
and the Voting Rights Act
which deal with ensuring that
citizens aren't prevented
from voting due to discriminatory
or arbitrary means.
But other than that
the elections are mostly under
the control of the states
and, if forced,
potentially states could
find alternative ways
to hold congressional or
presidential elections
with each state
secretively scheduling them
outside of the designated
federal election day.
Or conceivably if people
are physically prevented
from going to the polls no matter what,
then conceivably the state legislatures
could take back the
power of their electors
in the electoral college and
vote in the electoral college
the way that they think
that their state population
would vote in the general election.
Which, of course, would
be incredibly ironic
because it would actually be a good use
for the electoral college,
which under normal circumstances
there are simply no good defenses
for the electoral college
in this day and age
to thwart the popular vote.
- Two thumbs down.
- And anyone who tries to
defend the electoral college
is simply wrong, and/or
dumb, but I digress.
So, even if the president
successfully, albeit illegally,
thwarts the election and
electors never cast their vote
or their votes are never counted,
there are constitutional
provisions already in place
that we discussed that
would prevent his term
from naturally extending.
So, if the election doesn't go forward
then President Trump doesn't
just get to remain in office.
To find out what would happen
we'd just have to go
back to our conversation
at the beginning of this
video, which if you'll recall
is the fact that the president
shall hold his office
during the term of four years
and specifically the 20th Amendment,
which provides for an
end date of that term
which provides that the
president's term shall expire
on noon on the 20th day of January.
So, if there is no election,
then by default the president's
term ends on January 20th.
One way or another he's
out of the White House.
This doesn't depend on
President Trump's willingness
to vacate the White House.
Legally, he is no longer the president
and I suspect if he stayed there,
there would be some big
men with green uniforms
and big pointy guns
that would remove him
from the White House.
- Unless they give me an
extension for the presidency.
- But if President Trump isn't
the president then who is?
Let's play this scenario out
just a little bit further
because we've established
that President Trump
is no longer the president
come January 20, 2021.
But that still begs the question, who is?
Now, I'll tell you who
would become president
but first I wanna tell you
who should become president,
that's Jose Andres.
Jose Andres is basically the
patron saint of DC these days.
The world-famous chef created something
called the World Central Kitchen
to feed those in need during
natural and manmade disasters.
They were on the ground in
Puerto Rico for Hurricane Maria
and they're out in the
streets helping people
during this pandemic.
They've already served
over 15 million meals.
I just gave $500 and it
would mean the world to me
that if you're in a position to give,
if you could give a little bit as well.
The link to the website
is in the description,
every little bit helps,
and it would be great
if we could come together
and help people during
this coronavirus pandemic.
But, the question is who
would become president
in this crazy situation
where there was no election?
Under normal circumstances,
the constitution
and the federal statutes
provide an order of succession
for who would take over
the powers and duties
of the office of president in the event
the current president is
incapacitated, dies, resigns,
or is removed from office
or in this case his term
has effectively ended,
and you may recall under
this line of succession,
which we have covered a
couple times on this channel,
under Article II of the Constitution
after the president it
goes to the vice president
and then precedes next to
the speaker of the house,
the president pro tempore
of the Senate and so forth
under the Presidential Succession Act.
Now first things first,
we can eliminate some of these options
because under this hypothetical
there hasn't been an election.
And so just as the president's
term expires on January 20th
so too does the vice
president's term expire.
So the vice president
can't pick up the mantle
for the president whose term
has expired on the same day.
And then next, we can't
necessarily give the presidency
to the speaker of the
house because remember,
members of Congress are
reelected every two years.
So every time there's
a presidential election
all of the congresspeople
are also reelected.
So if there is no general election
then there aren't going to
be any members of Congress
in the House of Representatives.
There might be some people in the Senate
because they're elected on
a six-year staggered basis
but there would be no members of Congress,
for the most part.
So this creates a bunch
of really, really weird
Constitutional scenarios,
but we know a couple things for certain.
Number one, we know that the
president's term expires,
so that president can't remain president.
Number two, vice president's
term has also expired.
We know that there aren't
any members of Congress,
presumably, at least in the first instance
so there's no speaker of the house.
So that leaves a couple
of really weird scenarios.
Number one is that if
these state legislatures
or the state governors got together
and just simply agreed to reappoint
all of the members of Congress,
then you have a sitting body
in the House of Representatives.
If that's the case, then President Trump
would have to swallow hard
when he finds out that,
that means his archenemy Speaker
of the House Nancy Pelosi
would now be filling his shoes
as the third in line of succession.
Now, the other option would
be that those in Congress
whose term was set to expire
would not be reappointed,
which would completely abolish
the House of Representatives,
at least in the short term,
since they're all voted
on every two years,
and at that point what we have
is 2/3 of the senators left
since 2/3 of the senators
weren't up for reelection
but 1/3 were up for reelection.
So in this scenario, we have no president,
no vice president, no
speaker of the house,
and no members of the
House of Representatives.
What that means then is we
would go to the fourth person
in the line of succession
which would be the president pro tempore
of the Senate as the acting president
because they're next
in line for succession.
Now, you can be forgiven
if you have forgotten
your high school civics.
The president pro tempore of the senate
is generally the oldest serving member
of the majority party in the Senate
and in this case that would
be Senator Chuck Grassly,
the republican senator
who is 85 years young
from the great state of Iowa
who is currently the president
pro tempore of the Senate.
So, does that answer the
question, President Chuck Grassly?
Well, probably not because remember I said
that 1/3 of the senators are
actually up for reelection
in this election cycle.
So I don't think that the state governors
are just going to sit idly by.
They would probably
appoint interim senators
to fill the gaps left by the senators
who were up for reelection.
And so then you have to look
at how many of the vacancies
would be filled by republican governors
and how many vacancies would be filled
by democratic senators?
And thankfully the math
has already been done
by Andrew at Opening Arguments
who figured out that there
are more democratic governors
who would fill vacancies
than republican governors
who would fill vacancies.
So, at the end of the day,
of the senators who are up for reelection
and are being reappointed,
that probably means
that there would be a democratic
majority in the senate,
which means that the president pro tempore
would be nominated by the democrats
and the senior most democratic
senator in the Senate
is none other than
Vermont Senator Pat Leahy.
So, we can all welcome President
Pat Leahy to the office.
So there ya go.
In the wildest of twists,
the most likely outcomes
if President Trump
were to somehow cancel the election
is either President Nancy
Pelosi or President Pat Leahy.
I don't really know how to feel
about either of those two scenarios.
But after all of these crazy hypotheticals
and rabbit holes that we've gone through,
I'll say one more thing
to ease everyone's mind.
There is no plausible way
in which the president could cancel
or even postpone the election
and remain president.
We have held presidential
elections in multiple world wars,
in civil wars, in past pandemics,
and even when the White House
was burned to the ground
by the British.
As we've done in the past,
we will elect our next president
the good old fashioned way
and we will not have to
deal with a President Pelosi
or President Leahy.
Now, if you're waiting to see
what happens to our democracy
and our economy and you wanna
do some good for this world,
I'd recommend Tab for a Cause,
which lets you raise money for charity
just by opening new tabs
in the browser window,
which you were gonna do anyway.
Tab for a Cause is a
Google Chrome extension
that allows you to pick
the charity of your choice
then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of a blank page,
it displays a beautiful
new customizable tab
with a couple of tiny ads,
and the money that you
generate is then donated
to your charity.
You can see in real time how
much money is being generated
and it's gamified so that every
time you open up a new tab
you create a heart which then
you can specifically donate
to the charity of your choice.
Tab for a Cause is partnered
with several COVID-19-specific
charities as well
so you can fight the effects
of the coronavirus directly.
And the best part is
the gorgeous new tab
is really helpful too.
You can customize it with graphics.
I like to see pictures of the outdoors
to remember what that actually looks like.
You can create bookmarks,
create to-do lists,
and write yourself notes,
which I find really, really
helpful when I open a new tab.
All you have to do is click
on the link in the description
and install the Chrome extension
and it works automatically.
Tab for a Causers users like you
have raised hundreds of
thousands of dollars for charity.
It's the easiest possible
way to give to charity
and you could even just sit there
and just open up a bunch of tabs for fun.
So just click on the
link in the description
and download the
extension and do some good
by doing what you were gonna do anyway.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and click on this playlist over here
with all of my other analysis
about all of the legal
issues surrounding COVID-19
and just click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.